nous allons revenir sur ce fameux face à
face historique entre les deux hommes
maintenant sur ce plateau de débat doc
avec nos invités Christophe projetson
pour commencer bienvenue vous êtes
historien de la France contemporaine
spécialisée dans l'histoire culturelle
de la politique et directeur d'études à
l'École des hautes études en sciences
sociales le Hess que vous avez par
ailleurs présidé c'était entre 2017 et
2022 et vous êtes l'auteur entre autres
de voyage d'un historien à l'intérieur
de l'État publié chez Fayard c'est votre
dernier ouvrage Philippe Colin a
également avec nous bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes animateur et producteur de
radio auteur de série de podcasts à
succès sur les grandes figures
historiques baptisées face à l'Histoire
et diffusé chez nos confrères de France
Inter vous avez entre autres consacré
l'une de ces séries à Léon Blum et une
autre à Philippe Pétain dont vous avez
d'ailleurs tiré un ouvrage qui s'appelle
le fantôme de Pétain publ France Inter
Flammarion je crois qu'il y a un ouvrage
en préparation cette fois à propos de
Léon Blum
voilà comment vous vous définissez
d'ailleurs Blum dans l'un de votre
podcast dans 10 parisiens aduler par les
ouvriers redoutés par le patronat Haye
par les réactionnaires et les
antisémites le leader socialiste fut au
carrefour des fractures de la société
française de l'entre-deux-guerres on
commencera par là dans un instant on va
le faire aussi avec Frédéric salaballo
bienvenue bonsoir vous êtes avocat
ancien secrétaire général de la
présidence de la République aux côtés de
Jacques Chirac c'était entre 2005 et
2007 votre dernier ouvrage est consacré
justement à Léon Blum et il s'intitule
Blum le magnifique du Juif belle époque
au leader socialiste ouvrage publié aux
éditions l'Observatoire il y a trois
actes finalement dans ce face à face qui
nous concerne aujourd'hui il y a celui
de l'avant guerre celui de l'occupation
et
c'est sur ce volet précisément que
portait le film que nous venons de voir
ensemble et puis il y a évidemment le
troisième et dernier acte ça sera le
procès Pétain après la Libération
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait qualifier
ce face-à-face duel Bloom Pétain avant
guerre
alors il faudrait peut-être commencer à
distance c'est ce que j'allais vous dire
s'il faudrait commencer par un paradoxe
c'est-à-dire que les deux hommes ne se
sont quasiment jamais rencontrés sauf au
procès alors sauf au procès Pétain ce
qui n'était pas forcément le meilleur
moment pour une rencontre ils se sont
vraisemblablement croisés dans
l'entre-deux-guerres au sein de la
Chambre des députés ils ont discuté
dans des couloirs mais on n'en sait rien
et surtout du côté de Pétain il n'y a
pas d'écrit contre contre Bloom comme il
y en a par exemple sur un autre pour un
autre personnage qui est proche de
Pétain pendant l'occupation qui est
charmorace qui est là avait dans son
viseur si j'ose dire
Léon Blum en permanence
le Juif le Juif Bloom mais au-delà je
pense même l'intellectuel Blum tout ce
que peut représent le républicain Bloom
puisque à la fin des fins comme vous le
savez c'est selon sa fameuse formule
invitant à ce qu'on assassine qu'on
exécute blue mais de dos c'est une de
ces formules très célèbres ou alors
encore lors de son procès au mois de
janvier 1945 je parle du procès de
Charles Moras et non pas celui de Pétain
lorsqu'il dit au fond
cette fois-ci à son tour visé c'est la
vengeance de Dreyfus ce qui revoyait
aussi un passé de Léon Blum puisque Léon
Blum s'est fait aussi connaître bien que
son rôle était assez limité au moment de
l'affaire Dreyfus à la fois comme un
intellectuel et surtout d'ailleurs comme
un intellectuel comme un socialiste qui
est devenu sous l'influence de Jaurès et
de son ami le bibliothécaire de l'École
normale supérieure Lucien R et puis
aussi comme juif si on regarde ce qu'on
était les correspondances de pétains
est-ce qu'on en trouverait une néanmoins
attaquant frontalement Léon Blum durant
cette période d'avant-guerre alors là
vous me posez une colle je n'ai pas
fréquenté les de Pétain mais en tout cas
il est évident que Bloom n'est pas une
obsession pour Pétain comme comme il
l'est encore une fois pour celui qui
allait être un de ses conseillers
politiques pendant l'occupation Charles
Maurens alors Philippe Colin vous vous
dites Léon Blum à concentré sur lui
toutes les haines aucun autre leader
politique français du 20e siècle doit dû
affronter autant de violence ça c'est
peut-être pour recontextualiser
l'avant guerre et ce qui était ce que
représentait le houblon pour une
certaine frange politique française
avant guerre on a perdu un peu cette
mémoire aujourd'hui mais on ne sait pas
à quel point il a dû affronter cette
haine antisémite de la part de l'extrême
droite française et d'ailleurs d'une
certaine droite c'est inouïe quand on
reprend les archives on parlait de
Mauras mais pas que c'est des lettres
anonymes il reçoit sans cesse des
menaces de mort c'est assez inouïe je
rebondis juste sur les propos de
Christophe Rochasson parce que ayez en
tête que à la fin des années 30 le
maréchal Pétain est considéré comme
républicain comme haramarès républicain
c'est très important parce que Bloom lui
va prendre quasiment position pour péter
en 39 lorsque la République va mandater
Philippe Pétain comme ambassadeur de
France auprès de Franco en Espagne pour
donner des garanties finalement à cette
dictature d'extrême droite qui vient
menacer la frontière du Sud Léon Blum
dans le populaire dirait que c'était un
digne du grand maréchal Pétain c'est à
dire qu'à ce moment-là on ne sait pas ce
que va devenir philippe est un et que
Bloom a plutôt une forme de respect
distant à l'égard de ces militaire
français
c'est très important vous posiez la
question alors la relation elle est elle
est asymétrique en fait Bloom comme
beaucoup de Français comme l'immense
majorité des français à l'exception de
du général de Gaulle qui connaissait
bien Pétain et tromper très très
longtemps dans la venguerre par Pétain
Pétain apparaît comme un maréchal
républicain
dans toutes les campagnes qui démarrent
ces pétains qui nous faut etc lui il
joue la posture de l'homme qui au fond
est au service de la France et qui comme
il le dit dans une interview surréaliste
entre les deux tours de l'élection qui
va conduire au gouvernement du Front
populaire je ne fais pas de politique
après avoir dit les Croix de Feu
représente quelque chose qui a une
valeur très importante donc Bloom se
laisse tromper par cette image comme
tous les Français d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça qu'on bascule aussi dans le régime de
Vichy et qu'on a l'armistice il n'est
pas la capacité qu'avait de Gaulle la
différence entre de Gaulle et les autres
c'est que de Gaulle avait été le dauphin
de Pétain dans entre deux guerres et le
connaissait et il disait d'ailleurs
Pétain est un grand homme qui est mort
en 1925 c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait été
envahi par la vanité et la vanité
l'orgueil et puis une ambition terrible
qui va conduire à Vichy qui n'est pas un
hasard qui est le fruit de la volonté
profond de profonde de Pétain mais
pendant toutes ces années Pétain avance
masqué et vous avez tout à fait raison
de dire on trouve des propos de Léon
Blum élogieux sur Pétain en disant c'est
voilà c'est une grande figure qui se
dévoue alors néanmoins il ne fera pas
partie des 80 parlementaires
là le jeu apparaît déjà vici le 10
juillet 1940 qui donneront les pleins
pouvoirs Pétain il avait donc des
réticences
alors c'est un moment je vais pas
allez-y mais c'est un moment terrible
pour Bloom puisque il se retrouve dans
cet enceinte invraisemblable du théâtre
de Vichy où là tout le monde se liquéfie
face à la peur des Allemands face à aux
menaces de Laval et surtout il y a un
problème dans son propre parti c'est à
dire que socialiste socialiste 90
députés du Front populaire de la SFIO
vont voter les pleins pouvoirs à Pétain
ils ne sont que 36 à ne pas à voter
contre et là il y a une question qui est
évidemment Bloom votre contre mais ne
parle pas et donc est-ce qu'il parle pas
parce que lui-même est pris dans cette
espèce de maestro terrifiant de ce 10
juillet ou alors comme il l'a expliqué
je crois vraiment ça c'est parce que
surtout ce qui ne veut pas c'est montrer
la division de la SFIO et de son parti
oui sur les raisons d'y insister le
Parti socialiste est extrêmement divisé
c'est pas la première fois dans son
histoire ni la dernière
entre depuis
la fin des années 30 et notamment
unique le fameux moment durant lequel au
fond certains allant jusqu'à la paix
acceptaient au sein même du Parti
socialiste l'accord de Munich et puis
ceux qui le ceux qui le refusaient blue
mettant d'ailleurs un peu entre les deux
oscillant selon les moments donc à Parti
socialiste extrêmement divisé et qui va
encore plus se diviser au moment du 10
juillet y compris d'ailleurs parmi les
proches de Léon Blum il a beaucoup
souffert car Bloom est un homme plein de
sensibilité c'est un homme qui pas qui
pleure beaucoup
on évoque souvent les larmes de Léon
Blum au moment de la guerre d'Espagne et
de sa volonté de ne pas intervenir mais
un homme qui pleure beaucoup et ses amis
qui le lâchent en quelque sorte au
moment du 10 juillet 40 comme notamment
Georges Monnet dont il a été très très
proche est un des hommes avec c'est
l'homme qui l'accompagne lors de ce
grand attentat dont il est victime en
janvier 1936 un Bloom a été Philippe
Colin faisait allusion à l'antisémitisme
à la violence dont Blum et la victime il
faut rappeler cette attentat dont il a
failli périr en janvier 1936 par des
royalistes des militants de l'Action
française et de Mauras qui accompagnait
les funérailles de l'historien Jacques
Bainville et il se trouve que Bloom les
croise il a il est sa vie est menacée et
Georges Monet est avec lui et bien
Georges Monnet un très proche de Léon
Blum va s'abstenir de votre
appâts pouvoir mais il va s'abstenir ce
qui va blesser profondément son ami Léon
Blum précisant qu'il ne parle pas parce
qu'il a aussi très peur il va devoir
être filtré du casino de Vichy
il croise des gens dans un café des
Français qui sont là et qui sont au bord
de le molester donc il y a aussi une
grande peur chez Léon Blum de parler
parce que il joue sa vie en vérité c'est
ce qui est dit dans le film d'ailleurs
très justement que les menaces ce qui ne
voteront pas les pleins pouvoirs ne
dormirons pas dans leur lit ce soir je
pense que là la blessure et le sentiment
le plus fort et puis cette idée qui est
qui était celle de son père spirituel
Jaurès ne jamais divisé le Parti
socialiste était essentiel mais il y a
aussi Charles spinnas qui était très
important pour lui qui voyait comme son
successeur et qui va lâcher de manière
dramatique dans ces jours terribles
Pétain contre l'esprit de jouissance qui
a censé incarner le fond populaire nous
sommes le 20 juin 1940 autrement dit
très vite
ça style cette idée qu'il allait il
voulait voir faire payer le Front
populaire en les dénonçant comme ceux
qui auraient été à l'origine de la
défaite qui a soufflé à l'oreille de
Philippe Pétain cette idée de procès
c'est comme ça que c'est dit dans ce
documentaire que nous venons de voir on
a soufflé à Philippe Pétain cette idée
mais qui a soufflé à Philippe Pétain
cette idée de procès le sait-on
seulement
écoutez
je ne sais pas si on le sait mais il y a
évidemment autour de Pétain tout un
milieu politique dont Laval évidemment
est un grand représentant qui non qu'une
volonté qui est de faire la peau passez
moi cette expression un peu familière au
Front Populaire à tout ce qu'il a
représenté cet esprit de jouissance
alors même d'ailleurs que Bloom c'est
souvent expliqué sur ce qu'il avait
voulu faire par les loisirs que les
loisirs précisément parce que c'est ça
c'est
tout à fait la semaine de 40 heures les
congés payés que visent Pétain dans ce
discours que les loisirs ce n'est pas la
paresse précisément et loisirs c'est le
moment indispensable à l'ouvrier pour
reconstituer ses forces de travail pour
s'émanciper aussi c'est dans cet état
d'esprit là qu'il avait engagé
cette ce cette idée de loisir donc cet
environnement politique autour de Pétain
de droite d'extrême droite
prouver que saisir ce moment pour se
venger en effet de cette de cette
politique et de celui qu'il avait
représenté il faut bien voir ce que peut
représenter aux yeux d'hommes de droite
parce que certes il y avait une
peut-être une petite estime avant guerre
entre les deux mais Bloom un
intellectuel un socialiste et puis au
fond un homme dont employer un mot un
peu ça l'excise corporel la façon d'être
évidemment est à l'opposé de ce qu'est
un militaire
Léon Blum a des traits d'ailleurs il le
revendique presque féminin c'est un
homme à la sensibilité exacerbée c'est
un homme qui recevait beaucoup en pyjama
chez lui il recevait beaucoup de
personnes n’allités politiques chez lui
donc c'est le contraire de ce que peut
être un militaire et dans son rapport à
la France même les choses sont
différentes alors c'est le fameux
procédure ion qui va se dérouler en
février 1942 autrement dit
d'un an après c'est à l'option de
Philippe Pétain Bloom ne va pas être le
seul être jugé Édouard d'allier et le
général Gamelin sont également sur le
banc des accusés vous dites dans vos
podcasts que ce la préparation de ce
procès à occupé quasiment l'entièreté du
temps de Léon Blum qui lui pendant ce
temps-là est déjà incarcéré bien sûr et
déjà jugé par Philippe c'est un qui l'a
déjà jugé à être enfermé
forteresse forteresse en forteresse
c'est le la définition de la justice on
achète Pétain on condamne avant on juge
ensuite
oui il passe beaucoup de temps parce que
c'est sans doute aussi une manière pour
lui de répondre au 10 juillet 1940 il
sait qu'il va pouvoir préparer sa
défense il sait qu'il va pouvoir se
défendre il sait qu'il a affaire à des
gens qui vont être illégitimes les
magistrats qui le jugent ont prêté
serment à Philippe Pétain il sait très
bien c'est une justice un peu fantoche
et il va y voir une opportunité en tant
qu'avocat en tant que juriste de ce se
défendre et de défendre son bilan avec
Dala dit exactement évidemment
j'ajouterai une petite dimension par
rapport à Bloom est-ce qu'on peut
reprocher à Bloom c'est évidemment qu'il
est Juifs faut jamais oublier ça parce
que Bloom est l'incarnation d'une
rencontre entre l'histoire de France et
l'histoire des Juifs c'est extrêmement
important idée de l'incarnation de ce
que bird baume appelle pierre bien boom
un juif d'État et c'est pas rien parce
que c'est une définition de la nation
c'est-à-dire que c'est une sédimentation
d'éléments qui viennent faire la nation
française et dans la vision d'extrême
droite française portée par Philippe
Pétain ce n'est pas possible on ne peut
pas intégrer ces éléments extérieurs et
c'est bien aussi tout l'enjeu de ce
procédé rayon de dire qui est un bon
français et qui est un mauvais français
et Blue va dire non je suis français
aussi au nom de la République et des
valeurs qu'elle porte c'est à dire
l'universalité République dans laquelle
on peut mettre aussi les gaullistes
évidemment
si on a bien compris là aussi c'est
l'accusateur qui s'est retrouvé accusé
au final ce procès n'ira pas à son terme
oui mais ça dit beaucoup de Bloom il est
emprisonné à bourassol puis au Portalet
dans des conditions forts de portail
dans des conditions qui sont effroyables
c'est-à-dire que sa chambre gèle le
sauce sanitaire le simple sauce
sanitaire qui est à côté de lui gèle et
donc on va voir le Bloom tel qu'il est
c'est à dire qu'il prépare d'abord avec
une forme d'optimisme il a des phrases
qui qui disent beaucoup de son
tempérament il dit dans ma vie j'ai eu
beaucoup d'expérience pas celle de la
prison la Providence maintenant me
permet de le vivre donc il retourne le
caractère tragique des choses pour
toujours être dans le positif ensuite il
est il avait été conseillé d'État il
avait été avocat président du conseil il
s'extrait lui-même de sa propre
situation il se fait son propre avocat
et il va travailler de manière
magnifique à la préparation de sa
défense et effectivement il va renverser
les choses au moment de ce procès mal
conçu par Vichy parce que au fond
derrière ça Vichy c'est à la fois
criminel et grotesque c'est-à-dire qu'il
y a une conviction chez Philippe Pétain
que quelque part avec la Révolution
nationale il va transformer la France et
que la France comme la Prusse après 1806
saura se renouveler et sera se réimposer
aux Allemands donc il est dans un dans
une illusion complète et dans ce process
ça va se voir de manière incroyable pour
pour Pétain en réalité c'est le Front
populaire le responsable parce que
quelque part ça a conduit à la perte de
millions d'heures de travail pour le
réarmement et ça crée dans l'esprit des
travailleurs un goût de la jouissance
qui a affaibli la préparation de
l'effort de guerre ce que va montrer
Bloom de manière effrayante c'est qu'en
réalité d'abord pourquoi commencer en 36
alors que Hitler arrive au pouvoir en 33
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé entre 30 et
surtout 36 ans
doumergues et tous les autres et il dit
et le Front populaire c'est formidable
il y a eu trois parties une année
c'était moi une année c'était choquant
et une année c'était Daladier mais
Daladier et moi nous sommes là et
choquant le maréchal Pétain lui a confié
une mission expliquez-moi donc ça va se
transformer dans quelque chose qui est
un procès à rebours jusqu'à que Hitler
soit scandalisé par ce qui est en train
de se passer et disent maintenant stop
mais sur le procès d'Orion oui si je
peux garder une leçon par rapport aux
faces qui nous concerne je ne sais pas
si il y a une leçon mais ce que ce que
vous disiez à l'instant populaire
n'était pas
il faut avoir bien en tête le ciel de la
défaite de 40 bien sûr au contraire
puisque ne serait-ce que sur les
investissements fait en matière
d'armement le Front Populaire a fait un
gros effort
alors que c'est ce que montre Bloom le
pétales lorsqu'il était aux affaires
avaient plutôt pas plutôt avec diminué
le volume des investissements mais un
point qui est aussi très important dans
le procès de Riom c'est le sérieux
j'allais dire technique avec lequel est
préparé ce procès c'est pas simplement
le Bloom
je dirais rateur
qui était souvent salué bien qu'il est
une voix d'ailleurs assez assez fragile
on l'entend un petit peu dans le dans le
dans le film mais le sérieux technique
des chiffres des faits des informations
que lui fournissent ces anciens
camarades avec lesquels il a gouverné
permet de démolir littéralement
l'accusation qui reposait sur trois
principaux chefs les congés payés
les la semaine de 40 heures et les
nationalisations des usines d'armement
bon sur tous ces plans là Bloom a de
quoi montrer que c'est un procès un
mauvais escient qui lui est fait il
était accusés d'avoir trahi les devoirs
de leur charge c'était un motif qui
était déjà pas tout à fait clair à la
base ensuite c'est vous l'avez dit c'est
Hitler qui mettra et les nazis qui
mettront un terme à ce procès et c'était
si Hitler qui décidera de déporter Léon
Blum à bukenval alors pas exactement
dans l'enceinte du camp à l'extérieur du
camp
mais néanmoins il fera deux ans de
d'emprisonnement dans ce camp qui était
absolument un pavillon de chasse qui
était l'ancien pavillon de chasse de
himler et qui avait donc là il était
avec George Mendel évidemment en
détention et Jeanne rachelbach qui va
venir épouser Léon Blum dans cette
détention ce qui est assez inouï et
profondément courageux de sa part aussi
et puis avec énormément d'écrit là
encore de Léon Blum pendant cette
détention des écrits très forts il y a
un testament qui les créations 31
juillet 1944 qui est extraordinaire
puisqu'il y a étant à bourrun Vald il
dit déjà qu'il ne faudra pas accablé le
peuple allemand il refuse il refuse le
côté race maudite comme il dit il n'y a
pas de race prédestinés
quand on y pense alors qu'il est en
plein burun Vald en juillet 44 George
Mandel est mort il a été exécuté par la
ministre française et Blum à cette
espèce d'humanité en lui de dire
attention
protégeons-nous de l'avenir et
n'accablement pas les Allemands je
trouve ça extraordinaire franchement oui
il y a un point que je voudrais je
voudrais souligner dans cette période
qui est un peu mal connue c'est le rôle
de Bloom en faveur de De Gaulle
de Gaulle est extrêmement contesté
évidemment en Angleterre mais surtout
des États-Unis Roosevelt considèrent que
c'est un Mussolini en puissance et qu'il
faut liquider et là Bloom de sa prison à
travers Daniel Mayer qui est son qui est
son relais au Parti socialiste et qui a
une image formidable aux États-Unis va
se porter garant du républicanisme de De
Gaulle et dire très clairement nous tous
les socialistes sommes derrière le
général de Gaulle et ça ça a un jouet
rôle considérable au moment où le
général de Gaulle était menacé d'être
liquidé au profit de Giro et au fond
c'est à la fois les victoires les Forces
françaises libres sur le terrain le
ralliement de la résistance mais
également d'un Léon Blum qui pour une
partie d'ailleurs de la SFIO va prendre
ce parti radicale en faveur du général
de Gaulle qui le protège et va lui
permettre de traverser cette période
difficile donc de sa prison dans son
appartement avec Pétain il va se
mobiliser pour le troisième homme en
fait c'est un affrontement à trois le
troisième c'est évidemment de Gaulle aux
côtés du général de Gaulle et sans
nuance c'était très important à l'époque
d'être sans nuance et il a
l'intelligence de comprendre qu'il faut
être gaulliste sans nuance alors ce
procès aura lieu le 23 juillet 1945
Pétain sera jugé pour autre trahison et
intelligence avec l'ennemi il sera
emprisonné d'ailleurs à Portalet
exactement dans la même forteresse où
était Léon Blum et quant à Léon Blum et
bien lui il va il va revenir évidemment
en France il dirigerait même le dernier
gouvernement provisoire entre le 16
décembre 1946 c'est le 16 janvier 1947
ça sera la transition à une certaine
manière avec la la Quatrième République
le procès Pétain là pour le coup les
deux hommes se font face à face
réellement physiquement
oui oui c'est c'est en effet
on l'imagine malgré tout avec tout ce
qui s'est passé préalablement que ce
face-à-face a dû particulièrement
émouvoir
Léon Blum
et on imagine aussi ce que Pétain a pu
avoir en tête face à ce qui a été son
adversaire même s'il ne l'avait pas
rencontré tout ce encore une fois ce
qu'avait incarné cette adversaire parce
que contrairement à de Gaulle qu'il a
rencontré et dit avec lequel il a
discuté avant guerre déjà comme on le
disait en début de cette émission ça
n'avait pas été le cas pour Pétain donc
oui sans doute un moment
particulièrement fort mais il faut aussi
rappeler que Léon Blum était opposé à
toute condamnation à mort et que il
n'était pas là pour faire condamner à
mort Pétain de même que d'ailleurs il
essaiera de sauver de la condamnation à
mort Pierre Laval donc ça c'est un point
malgré tout qui dit beaucoup je crois de
comment dirais-je de la rigueur de la
cohérence de Léon Blum qui ne cède pas à
la haine qu'il aurait sans doute été
légitimement porté à ressentir après
après ces mois et c'est moi mais c'est
là où il est surprenant puisque après
tout ce qu'il a subi il est il refuse la
haine c'est à dire que il y a des images
du procès qu'on voit dans le film on les
voit tous les deux très proches
physiquement après tout ce qui s'est
passé et on sent qu'il y a une forme de
d'humanité encore chez Bloom Pétain est
assis un peu accablé le regard
d'ailleurs un peu en position en
contrechant et c'est vrai que c'est très
troublant cette image de les voir si
proche a-t-il bâti son son témoignage il
était là auditionné par cette autre cour
de justice en tant que témoin sur quoi
a-t-il bâti son témoignage mais je crois
que c'est défendre son héritage toujours
face à Philippe Pétain redire à nouveau
pourquoi le Front populaire n'était pas
responsable
cette défaite et puis venir dire ce
qu'est la République puisque la grande
obsession aussi de Léon Blum c'est de
restaurer l'esprit de la République
c'est très important et il est il est
conscient de ça il a conscience que
c'est un procès pour l'histoire ce
procès Pétain en juillet 45 ans
égalité fraternité liberté-égalité-faire
notre fameuse devise républicaine
entre autres des frontons de mairie dès
son sa prise de pouvoir c'est un moment
de grandeur de Bloom parce que il arrive
et il c'est vraiment toujours la même
chose c'est-à-dire l'esprit de justice
au sens le plus noble qui
qui conditionne sa prise de position et
ce qu'il explique en réalité c'est que
le crime de Pétain c'est au fond d'avoir
couvert de sa gloire l'armistice et de
laisser croire à travers le fait que lui
était en faveur de l'armistice aux
Français que c'était un acte qui fallait
faire qui était justifié et qui était
normal ce en quoi il exactement la même
position que le général de Gaulle qui a
toujours dit le problème majeur le crime
c'est l'armistice alors c'est une époque
aussi où tout ce qui est du valdive
déportation des Juifs et pas et pas
connu et pas assez connu et très peu
connu mais ça c'est le cœur de sa
position et il le fait que la question
juive a été assez peu abordée à
l'occasion de ce procès parce que ça
vient plus tard c'est après Paxton les
les travaux qui ont été faits après les
années 70 notamment par les époux
l'arsfeld mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est autant quelqu'un comme Raynaud au
procès cherchait à accablé Philippe
Pétain et quelque part ça baisse autant
au contraire chez Bloom il y a
énormément de hauteur ce qui fait dire
d'ailleurs à l'avocat de Pétain Jacques
kizorni Blum ses comporté comme un
seigneur et donc il sait il s'est
comporté comme un Seigneur parce que il
a toujours été à travers ce qu'il a
toujours été son moteur c'est à dire ce
que vous dites République et justice
peux pas le rappeler c'est il a été
président du conseil dans les heures
sombres et c'est Pétain qui lui aura
c'est lui qui démissionne et pétard
arrive ce qui était pour la poursuite de
la guerre enfin c'était aussi quelqu'un
d'un peu compliqué un peu velléitaire ce
qui est très touchant et ça nous renvoie
au début de notre discussion c'est qu'en
effet
Bloom finalement dit que Pétain a dupé
les Français que Pétain a floué les
Français et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que peut-être qu'il parle de lui-même il
se dit que moi aussi j'étais dupé par
Philippe Pétain et c'est là qu'il y a
une chose qui est intéressante parce que
il y a une grande sincérité chez lui et
il dit ben voilà nous avons été dupés
par ce grand maréchal que nous estimons
tous finalement et qui a berné la France
et là il est très touchant pour ça parce
que c'est là où il prend une hauteur
d'esprit lui aussi mais pour cette
hauteur d'esprit je crois elle s'éclaire
d'un livre qu'on n'a pas encore cité
qu'il a rédigé en même temps que la
préparation du rayon de du procès de
Rion qui publie en 1945 c'est à
l'échelle humaine
et c'est assez frappant cet ouvrage
parce que on y voit presque j'allais
dire une dimension religieuse alors il
avait déjà dit en 1919 dans un écrit qui
s'appelle pour être socialiste que le
socialisme était une morale presque une
religion et donc on a cette espèce
d'affirmation de cette dimension de son
socialiste à la fin donc de la de la
guerre où ils rond d'ailleurs
définitivement avec le communisme
d'ailleurs les communistes a commencé
par Torres qu'il avait aussi haï dans
des termes parfois terribles pire que
l'extrême droite parfois en tout cas de
ce niveau là lorsque Thorez dit que il
est un
formule méchap tout d'un coup mais enfin
en tout cas c'est un support du
capitalisme
la pose bon bref tout ça pour dire que
il est plein de cette sensibilité
quasiment religieuse qui lui donne je
crois qui contribue en tout cas à lui
donner cette cette hauteur de vie cette
dignité il participera un autre procès
celui de la cagoule à la cagoule faut
peut-être appeler ce que c'est
en 47 là aussi témoigner en tant que la
cagoule était une extrême une
organisation d'extrême droite qui
organisaient des attentats des complots
visant des personnalités de gauche ou
démocratiques ou tout simplement
républicaine et qui était
plus ou moins clandestine enfin bon qui
n'était pas dans le droit fil disons des
pratiques républicaines est-ce qu’après
ce procès Pétain on trouve trace décrit
justement de Léon Blum
concernant Philippe Pétain ou est-ce que
la messe était dite et les choses
étaient entendues pour lui alors à ma
connaissance je ne suis pas sûr que Léon
Blum parle de Philippe Pétain après le
procès je ne le crois pas en tout cas je
n'en sais rien mais je crois qu'il est
passé à autre chose il a d'autres
objectifs et il va reprendre à ses
écrits dans le populaire etc mais je
crois pas qu'il reparle de Philippe
Pétain ça ne me dit rien dans ce duel
qu'on a évoqué ensemble après ce film
que nous venons de voir c'est finalement
Bloom qui a gagné par KO
le match était joué d'avance contenu de
la qualité de l'un et de l'autre
Pétain sur le plan politique c'est une
illusion complète il avait des l'idée
pour lui c'était de dire il faut que le
pays soit gouverné comme une armée le
général au-dessus qui commande à 5
personnes qui commandent à 10 personnes
et ainsi de suite la Révolution
nationale outre qu'elle a conduit au
déshonneur et au crime était grotesque
dans sa conception du côté de Bloom
c'est tout à fait une autre histoire il
y a un socle culturel considérable un
républicanisme qui qui se voilà qui
trouve ses racines aussi dans ses
origines juives et cette passion juive
pour la France et puis derrière une
expérience incroyable c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que que Bloom se comporte aussi
enseigneur tout au long de sa carrière
et à ce moment-là ça sera le mot de la
fin merci vraiment un grand merci à tous
les trois devoir participé à ce débat
doc aujourd'hui pour évoquer ensemble le
duel pète un Bloom Bloom Pétain auquel
nous avons assisté grâce à ce
documentaire que nous avons le plaisir
de vous présenter dans cette émission
vos réactions ça sera sur hashtag
débadoc sur Twitter merci à celle
massalik m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission comme à la coutumée et puis
bien sûr je vous retrouverai pour un
prochain débat doc et ça sera bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat à
très bientôt
[Musique]